van if we were gonna get a seven minute
lesson from you on writing a screenplay
so i've never written a screenplay
before but i had this movie idea
can you help me write that screenplay
in seven minutes not the actual
screenplays
um man uh you know
i'm not one an authority but if i had to
if someone if i was asking myself that
when i was starting what would would i
say to my
younger self um in seven minutes how to
start this
um what i would i would first off see
what's the story what's
what's the genre and and why do you want
to tell it
in three words give me three words about
the story it could be just three
three words revenge
um another word so we'll start with
those words then give me a character
who do you want in the character
then i'll go ask okay where's this take
place
um get the character what's the
character's job what does that person do
and what does that character want to do
and then
develop the world develop the character
and why do you want to tell that story
and we'll start from there and then
go out go back and then just even if
it's one page
or two page or three pages um
write something about what this
character does in that world with their
job
when what what they want to do and then
once you have that then we could flesh
it out a little bit more
and then then maybe like you said start
an outline
um what what what do they need what's
their obstacles
um and and then we add more characters
in
but i i would probably start with um
who the who the main character is and in
the world they're in
so then just quickly i'll give you my
character
is a waitress at a greasy spoon diner
off route whatever in texas okay
she's 40. she makes decent
wages there it's not really an exciting
job
but the owner of a local plant
has said i will make a deal with you and
that deal is i want you to listen to
what my employees say
when i'm not there and you're going to
report back and i'm going to put you on
payroll
okay all right seems like there's a lot
of conflict
there's some sort of like moral uh you
know dilemma as well and you got a
character
um and then what and then you could
explore
explore that explore the routes of is
she a good
hearted waitress is she does she want to
become the owner of this take out
the boss or does she want to fight for
who's who's doing
who um they're listening into um
so there's different routes in that so
it starts to what's
what's the the the the makeup of this
or hero or or protagonist because they
could be
like the joker he's you know he you
didn't have to be the best guy
but um what was this person doing and so
at least you have you have that and you
have that to start and then
um and then throw throw a couple
obstacles
and then and see what happens you know
uh because it could lead somewhere else
because you're just you just have an
idea you don't have it
yet formed so run with it run with
something
run with a direction and maybe write it
and then that might spur spur something
forward hence time back to the
daydreaming
because you don't know what could lead
because you're saying oh
actually she's doing this because she
wants to get to new york and because you
know why
because she she um
her you know um she gave up a daughter
and now that she wants to you know she
wants to go see that because she only
has six months left to live
and she wants to make peace with that
daughter and and tell her things
that she she wished that someone told
her
something like that so that's just
that's the
association disconnect and you could go
okay is that the story you want to tell
or you know or do you want a a
you know a drama or do you want it a um
a genre or horror film so so you stick
stick to that
and that that's where it'll lead and
what was the last part i'm asking myself
why do i want to write this
yeah why why i think you should all also
ask why
why do you want to write this what
like it's a question where because it's
going to drop
drive the narrative because um
it's that that's the question and the
answer is
your screenplay because it's it's
i think there's something in that film
that you create that you're trying to
investigate so
why do you want to write this what's
going on are you trying to
talk about um unrequited love
are you gonna try to talk about um you
know
haunted pass or you're gonna try to talk
about you know
what a new way out new living you know
hope
and things like that so why do you want
to talk about that and it generally has
to do with sometimes what
what's happening in your life you know
right now and it's because it's easier
to because you could feel like oh i feel
like i want to talk about
anxiety the loss of jobs the the loss of
the economy
being a new um homeowner not knowing if
i can make that how can i
synthesize that feeling into the script
of this girl in the diner
how to get that feeling anxiety in there
what she's going through you know
so that's how it would kind of
help usher it along and then just write
your first draft and
come with an image you already got the
image diner maybe the
opening shot is a bottle of ketchup who
knows and it falls on the floor
and she picks it up and sweeps it away
and then that could be
an image a theme that could that you
could hold on to
throughout um you know sparingly so
you're not
totally spoon feeding the audience why
is that a ketchup
is she part of the hunts family who
knows you know
do i know the ending
um do i need to know it
what if you write three endings put in a
hat and pick one
and then and go from there
so if a lot of times i think for me i
have problems deciding
so if if there's a course already set
and you know you have a couple of
different things you could try it but
then if it's a course you don't like
you revere back sort of like maybe
that's what i do in my life it's like
i'll try it if i don't like it i'll veer
back you know so
that's sort of like that process of for
me for writing
i'll go down on the road oh my gosh that
dialect's too
cheesy i don't need that character i
don't need to talk to the other waitress
i needed to talk to the mailman that
came and gave her a package that came
from new york
or something like that you know so then
the three
alternate endings could be she makes her
money
she leaves that town she doesn't look
back she sees her daughter
she tells her i'm sorry um
she has a sense of peace the daughter
has a sense of peace the other
ending could be she meets a good-looking
drifter
and he's a smooth talker and he says
darling i want to take you
to new york i want to see mama meet her
baby
and they go she packs he says hang on
i'm gonna get smokes at this gas station
he robs it
she doesn't know that she's in the car
now she's an accomplice
he gets arrested she gets arrested she
goes to prison
she dies there third
she's too scared to go the daughter says
i don't don't come
[Music]
and she ends up staying at this diner
and um nothing much happens to her and
she just kind of
stews in the regret yeah those are great
great great three things see so
with even with that we just spit bald in
two three minutes
and just write it a lot of times
we'll just sit there and wait for two
months or three months no this is not
working i gotta research this i gotta do
that
but if you stick to those feelings i'm
already thinking about the girl oh what
if
she came to the diner finally and then
you know like and just different things
so that's what happened that's
sort of what happens and you kind of
like go with it but
you never know where it goes unless um
you try it
so yeah that's good if she shows up yeah
say right why'd you give me up you know
right then you have that awesome or it
could be really like
that you know scene from the rest of the
wrestler when when she she uh the
daughter comes and
talks to make your work in that powerful
exchange of like
oh you know things like that so why
or it could be a thriller that she comes
back and
poisons oh gosh
yeah i like it
now i want to write this thing yeah
that's good
that helped i like to throwing the three
things in there and then
some of the other ideas i wouldn't have
thought about the daughter in new york
no you don't that's that's the so
now when you do that when you that's the
fun part when you start
then you read it out loud they're like
oh
things open up you know like so that's
why i think it's important to
not be holding to what you've done you
know because
it's like you should feel really good
that you've already
wrote it it's out there but if that
scene needs to go
it needs to go and a new one could be
born that's it that's the whole thing
and not be so precious with
with these scenes because um i think
that's
i think that's the scary part because
well at least for me i'll talk about me
again
sometimes you feel like you can't do it
like it won't be as good
or just it won't work or it's you
haven't thought about it
you know because it takes a lot of work
you know
yeah and you brought up stuff that i
wasn't thinking of and so and then i
i liked it better you know what you
brought up and and and you brainstormed
yeah yeah
what's the title of this
of uh the um let's see i love titles um
that's the hardest that's that's one
that kind of
do you what do you feel the title should
be waiting
um that might be too cliche sorry but
it's also
it's not just what she does but her
daughter is waiting for an answer
yeah she's waiting to start her life
so as cliche as it sounds there's many
meanings to that
yeah i probably would it takes me longer
with the with the title because that
would
that's sort of what would drop would
drive it um could be you know
is it more about the daughter or the mom
good question so you know
right i think it's more about the mom
yeah so so pick her middle name
and then jolene
she's a southern gal she's a southern
belle
maybe she won a beauty contest when she
was younger but she got stuck in this
town
and jolene sounds great yeah
yeah i think that's a good sounding name
or you could and then you could add
um or you could as you as you go
um maybe it's a letter that that
uh a phrase a letter that she she had
slipped
for the baby whenever she had or
something like that or
maybe maybe it's both of their names
jolene and uh jolene and izzy
you know i like that so maybe it's about
both of them so you and then you couple
them up
like thelma louise
and you have them drive off the cliff
sure and then there's a brad pitt
character too yeah gotta have that one
you gotta have that
and a dancing scene every great movie
has a dance that's true yeah
and every 80s movie had a great singing
scene
you